there's a singular moment
something most people will never realize
where all your efforts culminate to
deliver your dream
where you realize your purpose for cole
anthony that was now
back home in nyc and ready for the nba
drive
but it wasn't that simple
in just this hour chinese authorities
have traced a new deadly virus back to
the city of wuhan
the symptoms include fever difficulty
breathing
the first coronavirus death confirmed in
the u.s
the number of coronavirus cases jumped
by nearly 5 000 here in the united
states this has been quick
fierce fast and ferocious we have never
seen
anything like this before
i was never expecting it to get to this
level i thought they would have had it
under control by now but it's really
just gotten
out of hand which is crazy i am
officially declaring a national
emergency the coronavirus crisis is
changing so fast
the great shutdown of 2020 is underway
more than three-quarters of americans
are
under stay-at-home orders tonight just
being in new york being the center of
all this madness
i've seen that it's a lot of people
suffering right now
i haven't really had that experience in
new york saying everything shut down
there are probably a lot of things that
as a dad ga you're experiencing about
basketball in life
no one's ever been through what we're
all going through what have
conversations been like between the two
of you just me and my dad have been
pretty much talking once every couple
days you know there's been a few times
where he ain't reach out me to me for a
while and i had to
pretty much reach my hand out and try to
make sure he was still alive just
the fact that this is something that a
lot of people can go several lifetimes
without ever enduring
it's really crazy the entire sports
world just come to a complete hall it
must be crushing to some of the players
reports are that the nba likely will be
pushing back the start date of the nba
draft
due to corona i don't really think it's
changed my past i don't think it's
changed much
just in terms of my basketball i think
it's just really giving me the
opportunity to just be laser focused
focus on what matters at this point in
my life which is basketball
[Music]
a normal day in new york got into a
pretty comfortable routine and i'll
close the gym that i go to but they're
letting us get special access
after hours i mean i pretty much changed
my whole schedule
just so i can get in the gym at night
and then rest and repeat same thing
every day you're all right go
i'll get downhill get downhill get to
the rim i've been really in there with
these workouts and
whenever i get in the gym i go stupid
hard i'm going 120 whenever i get in so
i don't think i'm gonna fall is too hard
just from getting out of game [ __ ]
go get up get up to me
i think a lot of people are going to use
this as an excuse to pretty much
stop playing basketball just stop
working stop working hard
and i just i don't look for excuses i
look for
just every advantage i can get try to
stay ahead of the pack put it down hard
with nothing to do and nowhere to go
cole only had one mindset
grind despite everything going on in the
world
cole took this chance to get out of the
spotlight and just
work i don't think the coronavirus is
going to affect cole anthony's draft
stock
people are going to forget that north
carolina wasn't going to make the ncaa
tournament because nobody's going to
know
who was actually supposed to get to the
ncaa tournament i think in jenner has
been a very weird college basketball
season right you had a lot of the top
players
who weren't even playing another ball
wasn't playing in college
r.j hampton wasn't playing in college
james wiseman
barely played in college co-anthony was
battling injuries
so a lot of the big names weren't really
in playing college basketball
i'm very curious if you're an mba scout
based on whatever happened this season
how do you even graduate
cole anthony came in with as much hype
as you could possibly come in
with to college he was i think nba ready
when he was a junior in high school
perplexing freshman season
to say the least whenever you have a
really exposed player and they have a
knee injury it does take a hit
on the draft stock i would be able to
overlook that north carolina season hole
is someone who at every stage has been
able to
go through some bumps and bruises and
then excel
he came in with a lot of hype cole
anthony did unfortunately
with the knee injury his season was cut
short
his whole year was incomplete because he
had the injury then he had a team that
really
struggled he wasn't able to really
fulfill those expectations
he was going to be a top 10 pick
regardless the pieces around them just
weren't good enough to show how good of
a point guard that i believe this young
man could truly be
i think a lot of like kids just have not
dealt with adversity to this level a lot
of kids are just used to it going their
way
used to winning the majority of their
games really having dealt with losing
seasons having dealt with just
the struggles the hardships of a season
like that so i think all he can do is
benefit me in the future
big picture with cole anthony i mean you
still average 20 points a game this year
and 6-3 athletic and again you're
projecting long-term potential
i don't think teams put too much stock
into what happens
during a 20 30 game sample size in
college
the uncertainty had been crushing draft
on hold
quarantine midnight workouts no clarity
on the future
and finally it was announced nba draft
was slated for november 18th
next step in cole's journey has arrived
i just think that
to whatever team wants to take a chance
on me i just think you'll get someone
who's gonna
work as hard as they can every single
day
not gonna make excuses just gonna get in
there
work trying to make everyone around them
better who i promise they will not
regret
drafting there's rumors that
you know the knicks may be involved
would you like to go to the knicks
because of new york
i mean look hey it would be cool i mean
i'd be blessed enough to be drafted to
any team though so whatever team that is
i'm just i'll be
very thankful and grateful for that but
i'll give him everything i can
i think cole anthony to the knicks would
kind of bring back some of that 90s love
that everybody had
for the knicks
i think the city will get behind him
because one of us he's on your product
because he grew up here he's absolutely
not afraid of the light
you want a guy who really wants to win
and is the type of guy who can put a
team on his back
and that's that's called anthony he
loves the moment he loves the bright
lights i think that's
he's perfectly suited for new york i
really haven't thought about just having
a
legacy just in new york i just i've
thought bigger than that i don't want to
just be
having that legacy in new york one of
the lexi that goes throughout the world
in the nba there are those
perennial all-stars there are those
dudes who are at the top of the league
and i just i i see myself in that elite
category i mean
people might knock me for that that's
where i see myself and i'm more to hold
myself to that level
cole came up a prodigal son in new
york's crowded basketball scene
whether you believe he's the next great
point guard from the big city or not
nobody can deny this kid's home gave my
life to the game had my mama concerned
and made a call when she saw when i got
a return dude wants to be a legend
not in the shadow of his pops but in his
own right
said i'm gonna be a legend soon i'ma let
you know
i was a stereotypical kid from the hood
and the game was going to be my way
to do things in life that ordinarily
wouldn't be accomplished by people that
grew up
like me living where i live which is
completely different for my son i'm like
i lea i fight better with my back on the
ropes
he is as intense as he is not because of
some necessity
reason this dude really wants to be
really good at his crap
money isn't driving it you know and i
think that's the scary part
checks over grown neck bolder stones
ever since they said i'm going pro they
say i'm the next so-and-so
but you know how it go my favorite part
of cole's game is very easily
he loves to play basketball when i say
loves i mean with a capital l-o-v-e-s
all of them capitalize bull print
basketball is his deal
it's the real deal with him broke my
flow down they still came describing the
words
and all the work they say they put in i
gotta confirm he's got a purity and a
passion
just for the love of the game the truly
greats in our game
have always loved the game they don't
fall in love with the life they fall in
love
and stay in love with the game i don't
want to just make it to the nba just to
say i made it
for greatness that's one thing that my
dad tells me that he had that regret he
didn't want to be great
my ultimate goal of basketball is to be
one of the best to ever play said i'm
gonna be a legend soon
i'm gonna let you know i'm a legend now
they trying to tell me i'm gonna be a
legend soon though man i'm a legend now
[Music]
you